si me hizo una encuesta a 600 personas
de su escuela sobre su color favorito y
gráfico los resultados algunos colores
no están en la gráfica del chelsea
cuántas personas eligieron otro color
que no esté representado en la gráfica
de chelsea y bueno aquí tenemos esta
gráfica ella decidió hacer una gráfica
de barras y ella el listón algunos de
los colores favoritos azul verde rojo
amarillo rosa y gráfico la cantidad de
personas a las que les gustaba ese color
pero algunas de estas 600 personas como
en mi caso tenemos otro color favorito
diferente a estos colores que están en
la gráfica entonces nos preguntan
cuántas personas como yo eligieron otro
color que no esté representado en la
gráfica del chelsea cuántas personas
eligieron otro color que no sea azul
verde rojo
o rosa ahora la forma de averiguarlo es
observar la gráfica y encontrar cuántas
de estas 600 personas están ya
representadas justo aquí y así podremos
quitar es el número del número total de
personas encuestadas si quitamos ese
número a los 600 encuestados
encontraremos el número de personas que
no están representados en la gráfica así
que vamos a hacerlo y para eso primero
veamos el color azul la altura de esta
barra marca el valor de 90 entonces
90 personas eligieron el color azul como
su color favorito bien ya esto le vamos
a sumar la altura del color verde y si
observamos la altura del color verde es
de 135 eso quiere decir que 135 personas
de las 600 personas encuestadas tienen
como color favorito
ahora movámonos al rojo veamos su altura
y vas a ver que es 75 por lo tanto
podemos decir que 75 personas tienen
como color favorito el rojo y ahora
observa que el amarillo y el rosa tienen
la misma altura está justo aquí que toma
el valor de 120 así que a esto le voy a
sumar 120 y otra vez 120 porque es el
número de personas que tienen como color
favorito el color amarillo y el color
rosa
ahora bien podemos sumar todos estos
números y eso nos va a dar el número de
personas que están representadas en esta
gráfica y eso nos ayudará a encontrar
cuántas personas no están representadas
en la gráfica así que empecemos con las
unidades aquí tengo 0 555 es 10
+ 0 es 10 0 es 10 así que tengo 10 en
las unidades ya esto le voy a sumar y
ahora fijémonos en las decenas y si
observas aquí tengo 9 veces 10 más 3
veces 10 es lo mismo que 12 veces 10 más
7 veces 10 es lo mismo que 19 veces 10
más 2 veces 10 es lo mismo que 21 veces
10 más 2 veces 10 es lo mismo que 23
veces 10 y entonces tenemos 23 veces 10
o 230 y observa que este 0 lo estoy
poniendo justo aquí porque estoy sumando
las decenas y ahora por último fijémonos
en las centenas y para eso observa que
tengo aquí una vez 100 y le voy a sumar
otra vez 100 lo cual me va a dar dos
veces 100 y si a esto le sumó otra vez
100 me va a dar tres veces 100 por eso
aquí voy a sumarle tres veces 100
300 y de nuevo observa que tenemos dos
ceros porque estamos sumando las
centenas y bueno ahora vamos a sumar
esto cuánto es 10 más 230 bueno eso es
240 y si a eso le sumamos 300 me va a
quedar bueno primero tengo 40 y después
tengo dos veces 100 más tres veces 100
eso es lo mismo que cinco veces 100 así
que la cantidad total de personas que
hay representadas en esta gráfica son
540 pero nos preguntan cuántas personas
eligieron otro color que no esté
representado en la gráfica bueno para
eso recuerda que el chelsea entrevistó a
600 personas
ese es mi total de personas está justo
aquí y entonces a mi total de personas
que son 600 le voy a quitar la cantidad
de personas que ya tenemos representadas
en esta gráfica
que son 540 y eso lo que me va a dar es
el resultado de las personas que no
están en esta gráfica y es justo lo que
queremos si quitamos a los que están en
esta gráfica entonces nos quedaremos con
las personas como yo que tenemos un
color favorito distinto a los que están
acá abajo bueno primero si empezamos con
600 ya esto le quitamos 500 me queda
todavía 100 100 pero a esto siempre le
tenemos que quitar todavía 40 ahora bien
si es lo mismo que 10 veces 10 y si a
eso le quitamos 40 que es 4 veces 10
entonces me quedan 10 veces 10 menos 4
veces 10 eso me va a dar lo mismo que 6
veces 10
y ese es mi resultado entonces hay 60
personas que eligieron otro color
favorito distinto a los que ya estaban
en la gráfica del chelsea